[Musique]
mon
oui
[Musique]
tu y est allé un peu fort sur le sel
aujourd'hui chéri est ce que tu te
souviens de l'époque où jeunes diplômés
tu tu voulais exercer la médecine pour
les nécessiteux tu parles de l'époque où
je voulais sauver le monde heureusement
que mon oncle a eu cette embolie
j'ai pu récupérer son cabinet et dire au
revoir aux un t-shirt jamais ça te
travail quoi de quoi tu parles tu as
conscience
c'est drôle j'arrive toujours à détecter
humeur prémenstruel au des allergies
reviennent à les ressorts matin histoire
sur ordre du docteur et dans deux jours
tu seras comme neuve comme nev
quelle merveilleuse expression
malheureusement dans certains cas on
passe le point de non retour
mon but a les seins d'aller passer une
bonne journée et quoi tu cuisines pour
ce soir vas y mollo sur le scène
[Musique]
tenez bon encore d'y aller c'est la
sphère d'une ce grand caraquet désolé de
vous interrompre au docteur mais je
devrais être en pause depuis une heure
et bien dans ce cas je devrais vous
laisser aller déjeuner
notre personnel souffre de quelques
lacunes ils ont du mal à réaliser que
plus ils travailler mieux on se porte
elle se porte comme un charme
exact c'est la junte a donné à canal aa
excusez moi
sans vouloir me vanter je pense mieux la
connaître que vous aurez alors ressasser
rang 4 à femmes
c'est là non ça je l'ignorais vous
l'avez entendu vous
[Musique]
je propose qu'on opte pour la paire de
lèvres face à l'ogre lyonnais n'est pas
sérieux les deux autres demandes deux
fois moins de salaires et ont de
l'expérience
rien ne dit qu'elle sera lire nos
écritures tu sais comme toute entreprise
il faut soigner notre image et vu que tu
as voté contre l'aquarium pourquoi un
poisson rouge
on a déjà des paysages des montagnes des
posters en promo qu'est ce qui ne va pas
vendin ma patiente à l'angine blanche
m'a dit que ta femme lui a dit que ma
femme voit un psy incertain et d'albums
c'est ça et bien c'est sûrement vrai ma
femme sait tout sur tout le monde dans
cette joyeuse petite bourgade
elle m'a rien dit ça a forcément un
rapport avec sa mère alors vous vous
plaisez dans cette ville je me plais
beaucoup à quoi voulez-vous que je ne
suis pas d'ici tant il suffit de voir
votre coiffure excusez moi je sais que
vous avez voté contre moi mais vos deux
collègues ont quitté les lieux il ya une
heure et je vous attends je sais que
vous voulez caser un maximum de patients
dans la journée seulement j'ai aussi une
vie vous avez voté contre elle ça va pas
la tête
bon écoute je veux que tu mettes des
doigts dans tes oreilles je compte
jusqu'à 3 et qui souffle fort tu seras
bientôt les délais de cette vilaine
sucreries soldats préparez-vous et 2 1
et 2 2
amanda de chiens sont sous la lumière
artificielle
il était déjà moche maintenant ils sont
dépressifs et il consent keqin avec des
chiens sans pedigree eu un propos de
dépression tu n'aurais pas eu un coup de
fil de ta mère dont elle a le secret et
dernièrement un mandat un mandat
mais
tiens enfin à une crise d'angoissé
souffle dans le sac
on m'a dit que ça risque est arrivé
comme quand le fils que tu es tombé
dessus ta kwai la meilleure de clics et
je sais on a eu une longue conversation
ça s'est pas fait à la légère elle doit
sur cette lettre depuis un mois médical
appréhender mon départ elle et toi ici
tout seul
elle faisait que pleurer la pauvre toi
tu as cru cité une allergie
elle voulait s'accrocher jusqu'à ce que
je m'en aille mais elle était tellement
flipper que je vous ai dit qu'elle le
fasse maintenant il sole qui l'a pas vu
venir même les chiens refusait de se
nourrir
elle décrochera pas son porte un nom
pourquoi elle a envie d'être tout seul
coup et elle est assez voilà six mois
nous d'agir je lui dis je me tairai non
mais t'as été vu par des locaux est
pareil pour moi j'ai gloria âmes
errantes cette femme me détestent depuis
la fois où je les crues en sac et que je
l'avais félicité sortie foutu va rien
arranger si elle appelle entre temps dis
lui que je suis sur la route hockey
[Musique]
oui
wasquehal
[Musique]
elle t'a dit quoi exactement eh bien
elle m'a dit qu'elle voulait apprendre
de nouvelles choses
le violoncelle les nombres premiers et
qu'elle refuse de mourir tout en restant
vivant ne pas savoir ce que ça veut dire
elle veut aller à machu picchu une forêt
vierge au peyrouat
elle veut du temps pour se ressourcer je
lui dis d'accord je te laisse la nuit
pour réfléchir je l'emmènerais manger
des venir la semaine prochaine un
couscous
je crois qu'elle va adorer qu'est ce que
t'en fous tu compte en tirer avec une
plante
ce n'est pas juste une flore c'est un
bonsaï la vendeuse m'a dit que c'est le
le transmuter le transcendant dans une
seule entité
et je crois que je suis en plein dans le
mille avec son histoire de forêts
tropicales
[Musique]
aulas papa taratata là pour une surprise
je t'ai dit que je repasserai voici un
cadeau comme c'est joli c'est quoi un
pot d'herbe à chat gloria arrête c'est
un magnifique jeunes hyper que dit on
c'est un bonsaï le transmuter le
transcendant dans une seule entité
et comment il transcende sa nature en
développant des racines et des feuilles
à sa taille transmettez parce qu'il
vient d'un arbre plus grand et s'auto
suffit vous voyez cette forme
triangulaire ici ce triangle
représentent les trois vertus
nécessaires pour créer un bonsaï la
sincérité la gentillesse et la beauté
j'ai l'habitude d'acheter mes plans dans
sa pépinière curtis mon mari ben c'est
un vrai plaisir ben curtis et votre
femme pour mon jardin
à ma gauche j'en ai une qui refusent
d'habiter ici sans contribuer à quoi que
ce soit et à ma droite j'ai curtis qui
refuse de rester les bras croisés
parce qu'il a le coeur sur la main
voyez-vous mais surtout quartier c'est
un génie tout droit sorti de l'arrosoir
montrer mois plus tôt ou de mater les
rosiers c'est quoi un texan naturiste il
est horticulteur et nous vient du sud
jeu est sous type c'est sans importance
est mon ami et je n'ai pas trop en ce
moment écoute je suis au courant pour le
docteur et d'albums et quoiqu'il y ait
entre toi et ta mère je t'aiderai à y
voir clair
ma mère aussi été folle je t'ai dit
qu'elle coupait mes fringues et parce
que j'étais plus svelte lequel tu as lu
ma lettre ben oui et je sais ce que tu
ressens nous deux seuls notre enfant
quittant le foyer n'être plus qu'une
épouse une femme écoute si tu as envie
de te rafraîchir
il ya ce chirurgien qui bossent sur mon
palier il peut nous faire un prix il
peut te faire la poitrine le coin des
yeux tout ce qui te fera plaisir
je ne reviens pas la maison ben désolé
oh la vache comme ça pue et du fumier tu
sais être paysagiste c'est s'éteindre
avec la nature mais ici le pinceau sont
mauvais et au final tu as la chance de
s'en tirer une rose tu sais je m'étais
dit que si j'espérais très fort ton père
changerait qu'il redeviendra comme avant
mais c'est au dessus de mes forces je
peux plus rester là à espérer
il m'a proposé de me refaire les yeux tu
es sûr que ça va aller pour toi ça ira
et lui aussi ça j'en doute
survivra
et quant aux eaux
ne plaisent en l eau est venu se place
en haut r downy se plie au vha 2e place
enfin je veux tu te nourris ce ta mère
et moi sommes tombés amoureux sur cette
chanson il préfère un simplet je crois
qu'ils en retirent culteurs et ils sont
juste amis enfin je crois êter connais
ce type
j'ai vu plusieurs fois en allant la
pépinière et tu n'as rien dit à ton
pauvre père comment as tu pu me trahis
c'est pas ma faute c'est pas moi le
responsable
il faut que tu te bouges gros y'a rien
qui cloche chez toi d'accord syndrome de
fatigue chronique une maladie
neurologique une vilaine pathologie gros
c'est du flan une souffrent pas de ce
syndrome
tu fais médecine sans avoir quitté sa
chambre
wikipedia tu connais si tu l'avais tu
aurais des ganglions cervicaux ou
axillaires des douleurs musculaires
pharyngite difficulté à se concentrer
des mots tête j'ai tout ce que tu as dit
c'est logique avec tout ce que tu bois
comme alcool
tu sais ce que c'est de l'alcool jean
fisse primaire dans le temps tu sais ce
que ma mère m'a raconté
c'est avec ce cocktail que scott
fitzgerald s'est suicidé il en a bu
carte
c'était son écrivain préféré l'adoré
gatsby le héros de son livre et j'étais
un mec favori bah oui monsieur regarde
comme un étranger je ne sais plus qui je
suis moi du coup quelle pensée profonde
qu'elle a dit tu voudras lui glisser à
l'oreille que je suis un type profond
écoute toujours je te promet d'essayer
mais à condition que tu des soul
d'accord
[Musique]
conseille de se motiver
oui je dis qu est ce que je te dérange
pas désolé je t'empêche de jouer nos
chances d'observer gamme je te rappelle
sa les docks
c'est moi ou ton vieux ebouri ça fait
des heures qu'ils laissent et quad rugby
foulard c'est celui de ma mère
il aime l'odeur tristesse ça fait
longtemps qu'ils traînent en pyjama non
trop longtemps casting où sont les
escaliers pas derrière toi
alors vous êtes le vert vous êtes un
super soldat qui a pour mission de tuer
tous les aliens et les zombies
le truc c'est que c'est le quinzième
niveau vous voulez pas a commencé avec
le tutoriel
et gros t'as vu ça justin il défonce
carrément trêve il trouvait pas les
escaliers tu saisis
peut-être qu'ils devraient venir avec
nous l'amener en soirée on pourrait
laisser dans une chambre et juraient la
console dis moi que tu rigoles je vais
rester à la maison et tu crois qu'il va
inviter ses potes docteur à venir et et
qui vont se saouler et ruiné la barque
tu as gagné on va y aller pas et toi tu
restes ici ou si tu veux sortir tu
appelle un taxi d'accord
allez
ses leaders cette nouvelle soirée doc on
peut poser vos biens luxueux 43 nier
bonjour bonjour le trio prend ça dans ta
face tu as you go ça roule
qu'est ce que tu fais j'ai tué tous les
aliens et les zombies
du coup j'en commence en essayant
d'améliorer mon record personnel t'as bu
tout ce qu'a fait plus que ça c'est ma
deuxième carrière
tamera toujours adoré le café du bon
sens en fils et des litres je me faisais
un but refusé à 9 heures salle
extraterrestre mais c'est seulement tu
veux le récupérer ou pas la récupérer
avec la dégaine pathétique j'en doute
mais j'ai 2 millions de points tu sais
c'est tout sauf pathétique
tu me trouve pathétique justin ou dans
la moyenne tu sais parfois il faut
commencer par faire des efforts sur soi
tu vois mans est une femme absolument
incroyable encore faut-il avoir je la
vois presque tous les jours tu sais mais
ce que tu la regardes
je t'explique prend à ben d'accord je
parie que tu crois que c'est la femelle
qui a des couleurs de dingue
eh ben c'est le gars c'est le mal qui
fait le coup de l'arc en ciel pour
attirer la femelle est plus son plumage
est beau et plus là du succès tu vois où
je veux en venir
non tu veux rester planté là toute la
journée
oui comme tu veux
[Musique]
nerfs c'est tout ce que tu es capable de
faire il faut que j'aie déjà d' combien
tu soulevait on était jeune je faisais
médecine j'avais pas le temps alors
comment tu as fait pour avoir ce
merveilleux tort souvent torse
je suis né avec je ne touche jamais ce
que mère nature m'étonner ils sont un
peu plus elle va faire quelque chose
pour tes cheveux arrête de toucher 285
dollars je crois que c'est le droit de
les toucher à mettet les produits avec
tu crois que je vais me laver avec du
pollen d'abeilles août une l'ylang ylang
pour le volume il tire que je t'ai
laissé m'entraîner là comme l'était
fringues on est content quoi mes freins
carcasse dont mes fringues
tu crois qu'elles vont avec tes cheveux
du nord encore je suis censé être client
un espion personne dans le coin ne
portent cette couleur noire c'est pas
une couleur c'est l'absence de couleur
j'ai l'air d'un fossoyeur alertant dans
ce chalet si tu me fais ce qui est
normal quand on ignore les tendances
michel aulas mais pour qui
c'est une extension
tu pourrais les saluer la dernière fois
qu'ils t'ont vu tu trouvais pas
l'escalier et au boulot bravo énorme
amélioration d'auteur vraiment moche
piscine tulle et ça colle pile à vos
fringues d'un safari tés d'autres vous
vous déchirez vraiment si tu le dis
j'imagine que c'est un compliment 1
sur ce je crois que je vais vous laisser
entrer chaîne non non c'est vous avec
nous une seconde à les y passera une
minute et justin ou est-ce que tu étais
passez dans le coin a tellement à dakar
ça les salles ultime marque
je parie que vous saviez pas qu'il était
si populaire à ce sont des connaissances
pas juste des connaissances des
connaissances du genre spécial
j'ai soif on commande 4 soda du
guacamole tu veux une bière or vous avez
votre carte d'identité sur nous j'excuse
et moi je juste vérifier que vous avez
dépassé l'âge des grilles
enfin évidemment que j'ai l'âge légal je
suis bien plus de tout de même si vous
le dise je crois bien que si je crois
qu'elle s'intéresse à vous dr bingham
aura pitié je suis marié tu sais mon
vieux aussi il est marié il drague
d'aliments message oui je crois oui
certains à peine dias cool
venez donc tu m'as l'air d'avoir une
tonne de connaissances spéciales on n'a
jamais assez d'amitié à bénéfice mutuel
moi j'en ai genre 0 parce que tu dégages
0 qu'est ce que c'est censé vouloir dire
comment ça un bénéfice mutuel
vous vous vous parleriez de sexe partout
à bénéfice mutuel
il est mutuel parce que les deux parties
en profite
je crois que je suis en train de rêver
ici entre nous on n'est pas amis à
bénéfice mutuel
non la règle d'or c'est pas de mecs de
mon école parce que très vite tu
commences à avoir mauvaise réputation et
vous m'en voulaient ou quoi et combien
de ce genre d'ami es ce que tu as
jallet 6 1 vous avez vu la serveuse vous
a filé son numéro elle vous kiffe
mortels
enfin voyons je la connais à peine vous
devriez l'invité à la soirée avec nous
quoi ils écoulent go et c'est mon père
gros je commence à voir ce que tu fais
avec les amis jusqu'à 5 heures du mat du
bénef mutuelle
nous en rediscuterons
et votre bière oh oui il faut que j'y
aille mais merci en tout cas à quelle
porte wasit j'adore les hommes courtois
vous reviendrez je vous attendrai le
temps qu'il faudra
tel votre coiffure album a très très
bien
c'est gentil mais votre accord il
travaille au centre ville j'ai son
numéro si vous voulez ouais moi aussi je
voudrais ce coiffeur est un génie
bonjour docteur li shan veine trope
neurochirurgienne on s'est vu l'année
dernière à la tombola vent nous lui ai
dit vous savez ce que je me dis leur
vaut rien que je mange comme un cochon
non une personne n'a fortuit
je suis dans une association ou un test
jacques et phoebe sont dans une voiture
roulant à 80 km/heure 28 un train allant
à 130 kilomètres heure vers l'est
quel est le nom du conducteur du train
c'est une blague est une farce
alors est ce que ça vous dirait de
m'accompagner à la réunion mais de mon
association mardi prochain c'est un
buffet vous ne dépenserez rien du tout
et ne voyait pas gêné toute la ville
c'est que vous êtes séparés à l'eau elle
est là oui nous faisons la cuisine et
nous avons un invité
qu'est ce qui amène aujourd'hui
quelqu'un m'a dit qu'on était séparé je
sais qu'on vit dans une petite ville
mais je ne me souviens pas qu'on ait
décidé de quoi que ce soit ce ne sont
pas tes affaires au contraire je pense
que ça me concerne encore d'accord c'est
curtis
mais qu'est ce que tu lui prépare c'est
lui qui fait le repas au mandat
j'apprécierais que vous soyez un peu
plus silencieux et que vous respectiez
le fait que vous n'êtes pas seuls
qu'est ce que t'as pas ce que j'ai je
veux quelqu'un pour me faire à manger
qui cuisinent pour moi qui s'intéressent
à moi et qui s'assure que je vais bien
ok attendez je vous donne la moitié nous
enorgueillir plus ce qui reste de thé de
la guette le reste des beignets de
crevettes de zoé et et la fin 2000
cheikh tué répugnant je suis le seul
entendre sonner
salut j'ai dit sérieux à chaque rue
puteaux de langui fraîche du wasabi
maison et du gingembre qui pousse chez
moi et souchez c'est toute ma vie
vous vous êtes qui c'est moi enfin super
dégaine darlene on va passer une bonne
soirée hot dog vous défoncer attendez
vous allez où là moi je vais dans la
cuisine toi qui avais pas eu de la veine
qu'elle se soit pointé écoute ciment
s'intéresse son horticulteurs terrestre
tout le monde de savoir qui lui faire
dîner non mais par contre toi tu as bien
droit dîner avec son assistante
qu'est ce que tu dis mais je veux dire
que que je ne veux que ton bonheur or
merci et ce serait bien qu'en fin de
compte tu connaisses plus qu'une femme
avant de mourir non non mais tu oublies
hier qui tu parlais déjà tu es tu à la
maison pour toi tout seul je vais
rentrer tard vraiment tard alors profite
sois prudent
ça vient du fait que je vis avec ma
fille de 13 ans depuis que son père et
moi avons cassé on est devenus deux
soeurs j'adore son style je suis pas
qu'une infirmière en 2016 j'espère quand
même que vous êtes une vraie infirmiers
après tout vous êtes quand même en
charge d'anesthésier les patients merci
je suis pas très alcool show désolé
c'est fait avec du riz ça coûte tout
seul ça grâce je m'en passerais et quant
à votre porte accule vous allez trouver
c'est un peu nul mais quand je les
regarde je vois un chewing gum aquatique
il ya une chaîne hi-fi quelque part oui
dans le salon pourquoi petites minutes
[Musique]
c'est génial le hip hop c'est toute ma
vie
le sac et ce n'est pas si fort que ça
faisait mais je sais pas trop on dirait
une sorte de thé chaud qu'elle auquel on
enlevait le coup dit et je n'ai essayé
ça ouvrait la voie à les vider
[Musique]
je suis confus est-ce que tout va bien
oui ça va pourquoi ça fait longtemps que
je suis là
[Musique]
on connaît la liste comme moi je me bats
des anchois et rebondissements mais deux
vous êtes arrivé j'adore quand il
glousse difficile sur le mondial et
c'est contre les règles vous les
connaissez donc dans la même école c'est
contraire aux règles tacites doc salut
désolé pour le désordre c'est
l'inconvénient du sushi ils ont une
fâcheuse tendance à finir sur le
carrelage et j'ai pris du wasabi dans
les yeux et à partir de là j'y voyais
tout flou et où l'état de la cuisine
bah je suis content que tu t'éclates non
c'était horrible tu as des paillettes
dans les cheveux c'est difficile d'être
happé un modèle tu sais ça n'aurait pas
dû arriver seulement elle disait que le
sac était bon pour ce que jamais parce
que c'était bien vu duriez et à bimont
infirmières après tout bon tu y es tu
crois qu'elle ait oublié quelque chose
me dit que je suis sortie faire des
courses pas pourquoi tu n'ouvres pas et
qu'est ce que je lui dis j'étais saoul
et en plus il fait jour tu veux que
j'aille au vrai oui ok je vais offrir
mais tu dois trouver un truc à lui dire
il faut pas qu'elles se sentent gênés
d'être revenus d'accords bons joueurs
l'excellente surprise je dois avouer que
je me souviens plus trop de ce qui s'est
passé hier soir papa c'est maman elle
nous rend visite
c'est lui et quelle bonne surprise
désolé pour ta cuisine quand on est
entre hommes
le ménage s'en ressent et couché à 6
oubliez tout de suite du groupe
si je suis là c'est justement pour
récupérer mon vieux cabot il me manque
et qu'en est il de son vieux mari je te
manque
qu'est ce que tu as fait à tes cheveux
nouvelle coiffure qu'est ce que tu as
envie c'est différent c'est quoi ça ce à
quoi syrte ont cours qu'est ce qu'il ya
merci or voilà une méchante tâche
oh non c'est un bleu ça ressemble un
short de morsures d'araignées d'afrique
jeudi me faire piquer en rangeant les
débris derrière la maison ou quand je
peignais le scellier ou au montant au
grenier c'est pas grave ben ah oui mais
qu'est ce qui n'est pas grave tu peux qu
artiste est devenu plus qu'un ami pour
moi moi je vois à bénéfice mutuel
toi aussi tu ta donne à ces pratiques
comment oses-tu je suis venu chercher
sherman chessa le chien le dépressif je
suis bien plus déprimés que ce toutou et
il sera aussi quand tu verras ce que tu
nous as fait un béni oui j'adore quand
tu m'appelles penny il est évident que
nous avons réussi à élever un enfant
génial et maintenant il est temps pour
nous de vivre de nouvelles expériences
avec d'autres personnes de refaire nos
vies
écoute moi dans le sud les gens épouse
leurs cousins il va souffrir de
consanguinité c'est évident ou d'un
parasite salivaires et pour ta gouverne
la morsure et de mon infirmière pas
d'une araignée je dois voir son dossier
quelque part je peux faire des
recherches sur ses origines et vérifier
qu'elle ne vient pas du sua quoi
redescendre pour redescendre il faudrait
déjà que je sois monté quelque part et
sache que j'ai essayé d'être un enfant
pour reconquérir
j'ai un nouveau plus bas âge et toute la
clique et tu me rachète pour un type qui
sait quel engrais fonctionne avec les
marguerites marguerite au revoir ben en
soit bientôt série seulement
[Musique]
c'est dans la moyenne
je brûle intérieurement écoute
dis toi que maman est une équipe de foot
la meilleure les yankees d'accord et
quelle qu'elles veulent faire des
remaniements dans son effectif
donc peut-être que si tu passes ton
temps à t'entraîner que tu bosses sur
interflex tu seras à son choix numéro 1
pour la saison à venir
une bille de quoi tu me parles regarde
ce que j'ai trouvé sur le net
karaoké kipps un karaoké des années 80
alors quoi tu préfère écouter eva
l'honneur toute la journée où toutes les
chansons préférées et dis-moi ravenhill
se place en alors tu vois ça prouve que
tu maîtrises la musique des années 80
alors tu veux porter ta veste en velours
ou celle en la jette à l'eau non dis moi
qu'est ce qui peut se passer de si
terrible je vais transpirer et ma veste
sera foutu j'ai envie d'un thé glacé le
pire qui puisse arriver c'est que tu te
fasses rejeter mais être rejetée ça
arrive on a l'impression que c'est la
fin de tout mais mais c'est la vie être
rejetée ça arrive à les étiqueter le
contraire on va lui tenir compagnie
alors elle sait les l'a d'ailleurs tu
pourrais peut-être lui chanter les là ce
soir
sauf qu'elle avait des années soixante
dix mais c'est vrai qu'elle n'a pas
vieilli en tout cas moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le synthé c'est là
qu'on voit le talent être rejetée ça
arrive c'est ce que tu as dit aller en
piste être rejetée ça arrive être
rejetée ça arrive
[Musique]
m
balma
ouais
il est excellent excellent
chat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
son
[Musique]
ce qu'ils étaient
m
là c'est trop calme quand chez soi peu
plus respectueuse
oui
m
les caennais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui mondiale
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
et
des siens 2 1
m
[Musique]
problème est
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
elles m'ont proposé de me ramener et
genou retrouve chez elles parce qu'elles
veulent mon avis sur une danse
ensuite elles ont sorti du vin hélas
elles veulent me montrer la tançant
centric
elle sait les tranches de pain et moi je
suis le champion est ce que tu sais
combien de mecs rêverait d'être coincé
entre deux jumelles papa non à peu près
tous ceux qui ont passé la puberté et tu
te souviens de ce que tu as dit pour que
j'aille au foot tu m'as dit que si je
m'amuse à une minute c'est une minute de
plus que si je n'avais jamais essayé
j'ai dit ça et qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ensuite des rentrées dans l'équipe et
j'ai fini capitaine alors essaye et si
tu n'aimes pas tu m'appelles et je viens
de chercher le premier juré promis
tu sais bien qu'on soit identique il ya
des choses qui me différencie
elle a par exemple ses traits d'un
tatouage juste ici parce qu'elle adore
neptune l'océan et les vikings le 6 et
elle est là ces symboles de la chimie
parce qu'elle évite et son chiffre
fétiche débat
[Rires]
ben c'est quoi ton signe distinctif
non je n'en ai aucun ah je ne crois pas
je suis sûr qu'il tient sur les yeux
[Musique]
bonjour salil docteur bingham appelez
moi ben bon si je paie une fois par mois
est-ce que ça revient moins cher que de
payer au fur et à mesure on fréquente
des centaines de doctes vraiment et si
je n'utilise pas vos serviettes vous me
facturer les 50 djimba souvent malade
c'est juste je préfère prévenir que
guérir et j'adore la médecine en général
et puis avec des parents juifs j'ai
toujours droit à un avocat ou un docteur
mais entre nous je déteste les avant
qu'un pas et que oui quelle coïncidence
ce sont des temps durs quand est-ce
qu'on commence et je crois que c'est
déjà fait oui vraiment ouais une
cantatrice d'opéra
je ne pensais pas qu'elle chanterait
j'ai localisé et retiré le module elle
m'envoie les cartes de voeux tous les
sens drainera bull est héroïnomane
devenus insensibles aux odeurs je
l'ouvré et j'aurais par la totalité de
son système olfactif avancé rien de
moins
je n'ai jamais fait d'opérations a été
rouverte mais j'ai observé et je crois
que si je me retrouve en afrique et que
la vie d'un enfant est en jeu je me
sentirais de le faire
l'impressionnisme je viens d'avoir un
cours avec anna rosenblum 1 je me
demandais si elle était libre de manière
générale oui on colle quand même
j'hallucine que ton que nous paye nos
tickets pour arctic monkeys il se sent
minable de sortir tous les soirs si
seulement mon père était comme les tiens
j'aurais droit c'est sur un vaisseau
interstellaire au moins ils coulent
infirmière qui aurait pas un souci
d'éthique
elle est allé bosser pour un neurologue
donc ça va et sinon il t'a dit ce qui
s'était passé avec les hummer tu as
vraiment cru qu'il allait en parler à
son fils
ouais mais nous c'est différent tu vois
tout ce que je sais c'est qu'elles ont
une boîte de livraison à domicile des
trucs du genre amuse bouche des trucs
sexuelle genre hors d'oeuvre tu connais
les petits fours ce genre de trucs et ta
mère se fait jardinier
donc ils sont exactement comme les vieux
les miens sauf qu'ils se cachent
je hais les ordres
[Musique]
justin à 12 heures
mais moi c'est ton dclear ouais pas mal
ouais ouais pas mal
est ce que je peux merci beaucoup
france
[Musique]
pas
oh
[Musique]
13 chacun pressent 50
ou alors on donne 16 on prend un truc à
emporter pour le concert on se rejoint
après je vous laisse un grand les arctic
monkeys je peux vendre ton billet
[Musique]
ouais et
m
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
vraiment
alors il est comment raconte qu est ce
qui s'est passé est ce que c'était du
genre boum c'est de la bombe tu sais
quand t'es cool c'est cool
sauf que quand tu es trop cool sarthe
ont été plus cool du tout où ce que tu
essayes de me dire c'est que c'était
tellement cool que ça me dépasse si tu
le dis je te laisse tranquille non je
m'en fiche je t'assure j'étais police et
tout s quel genre interactions interne
ou externe ou n'importe quel genre
d'interaction tout à l'heure où est ce
qu'il ya eu des échanges de regarder
désolé et orbi vous voulez pas sauvé mon
record il faudrait que j'y aille mais
aller pour moi
hayami dessous chics a appelé tout à
l'heure vous aviez prévu de manger
ensemble ce soir
cette partition c'est ce qu'à la vie
mais je dînais avec la femme juive ce
soir c'est shabbat l'on mangeait un truc
spécial est aussi un cabinet avec elle à
vos airs dîner avec l'autre après et
c'est légal doc quand on vous courent
après c'est vous qui faites les règles
est tué votre casquette en mon dieu mon
coiffeur m'avait prévenu que ça risquait
de devenir terne alors que c'est uber
cool s'allumant gêne là bas vous êtes
sur wii vous étiez fait pour être comme
ça tu crois que ça ira je veux dire est
ce que ça ira pour le premier et le
deuxième dîner je ne suis pas obligé de
me changer entre les deux je m'amuse
comme un petit fou chacun commence à
avoir du succès c'est populaire tel fils
tel père non j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
tue c'est une fille voilà qui ne me
donne pas non elle est différente cool
ça pimente les choses pas vrai bon sous
la couche est ensuite sushis et boostera
mai et 5 eca part je peux emprunter des
baskets de ville
je me sens pas d'y aller en mocassins
ont fait la même pointure bougera est ce
que je t'ai déjà remercier de m'avoir
transformer en absolument géniale est
bluffant bref merci et du fond du coeur
fiston je t'adore
[Musique]
on attend à gauche et balouches attaque
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais la neige à la tentation sida
les mines à metz m mais décolorés année
dolmen
laura
n'est ce pas une odeur merveilleuse un
brin de toi c'était encore mieux que je
peux demander à ton autographe si ça ne
dérange pas oui aucun problème bonne
soirée à l'arrêt
merci d'être venus j'ai adoré le
spectacle et votre talent est ce que ça
te dirait un de ces quatre continents
semble quelque part où qu'on aille boire
un verre tous les deux ont pareillement
j'ai maintenant bien si tu veux être moi
d'accord ok génial ah ça fait très
plaisir je vous suis il discute de sa
performance de ce soir des élèves qu'à
la fête
il m'a semblé qu'elle était parfaite
mais ça c'est parce que tu ne connais
absolument rien aux balles et peut-être
non mais j'ai vu ce qu'elle vaut
tu sais valeria un petit ami là bas dans
son village à luz
ils sont bien ces je n'arriverai à rien
avec elle j'étais amoureux d'elle
pendant plusieurs années et elle ne fais
que penser à son petit ami
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me demandais est-ce que tu serais
partant pour qu'on aille boire un café
demain raté
les modes g découlent alors après des
coups j'ai toujours des cool j suis
désolé
d'accord ça fait rien je comprends comme
autrefois
[Musique]
bonjour salut il est chouette en fuite
c'est un jean
il est chouette et les styles et c'est
gentil tu es blanc et si on libérait les
deux monstres
est ce qu'on risque grand chose moi ce
soir
oui j'ai eu justin au téléphone et il
m'a raconté ce qu'il vit en ce moment et
je voulais qu'on en discute tous les
deux de vie voit qu'on discute de quoi
au juste
ben il est amoureux il est vraiment
amoureux mais oui d'une danseuse au moi
j'ai des doutes et pourquoi ça parce
qu'il ne m'a rien dit il ne connaît pas
que danseuse
il l'a rencontré dans un restaurant elle
vient de russie
il est totalement fou d'elle c'est une
ballerine j'aurais aimé qu'il est en
parle mais il a dû croire que tu ne
serais pas très réceptif avec la vie de
patachon que tu mènes ces derniers temps
leicester il le fait à chaque fois
comment ça ma vie de patachon raid ben
tu pousses avec ton infirmière et une
gymnaste et des jumelles c'est une
petite ville marché cette ville
c'est une coach pas une gymnaste lesnar
viennent ici un mandat je sais que ce
n'est pas bien mais je ne suis qu'un
homme tu sais tu vas arrêter leicester
regard de leurs justement il a été coupé
mais il veut se prouver quelque chose et
moi et moi j'ai pas été coupée et c'est
une période très différente pour chacun
de nos supers d'activités nature
changement côté moi je suis de cette
longévité dont les sommes sont tous
pourvus pourquoi cette injustice que
j'en sais rien mais merci c'est injuste
mais après tout c'est comme ça autant en
profiter
je veux qu'on vende la maison c'est une
maison familiale qui a maintenant perdu
cette vocation pour nous pas la peine de
prévoir de pension
je ne supporterais plus de dépendre de
toi sherman donc où veux-tu ans venu du
tiers des demandes d'audience sherman
dernièrement mon seul objectif c'est est
d'attirer l'attention ayant ghz et
devine qui soulignant qu'ils amendent a
fait c'est toi tu es les yankees ce
qu'est ce que tu fatigues en approche
outre les allemandes à amanda fiston
nous avons besoin d'avoir accès à ta
chambre si on veut vendre la maison
je sais qu'en ce moment c'est dur pour
toi comme pour nous tous il faut que
j'établis un contrat ta mère m'a dit que
tu avais rencontré une ballerine russe
je voudrais que tu saches que l'amour
est parfois comme ça il te donne mal à
la tête
ils te rendent nos yeux ils te donnent
l'impression que tu vas crever mais ce
n'est pas une façon pour sauter le petit
déjeuner tranquille je pense que je vais
revenir lundi
comment j'avais l'esprit ailleurs
vous voulez tenter votre chance faisons
le dans les règles vous en voulez je les
fais moi même je suis tenté mais
j'essaye d'éviter les sucreries dogs une
tuerie zoé arrête d'insister allez y
goûter d'accord d'accord
juste une bouchée alors tu vois tu la
maison
bien sûr je me disais que tant ses amis
vous pourriez lui parler le faire sortir
de sa chambre
l'amour c'est bizarre gros dr by tu peux
m'appeler gros traits parisot il
refusera de nous en parler
c'est comme jeter un ballon sur un
rideau ben quoi sur quoi et bah ça vous
le renvoie pas
je suis en retard pour un brancard les
jumelles on est au courant c'est cool
vous trouvez eh bien vous l'avez deviné
c'était une des jumelles voient sa soeur
non quelqu'un d'autre alors là bravo
gros
vous défoncer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi est-ce que c'est fait si mal
d'être à mort à quelqu'un jusque état
d'un coup dis-lui me dire quoi
lm david chat qui je te hais zoé mais
non tu me mets pas ça à cause du
moelleux au chocolat
ouais tu deviens tout celle où quand et
défoncé ce kit david chat
le musicien le métal celui de la fanfare
défense et elle je vois celui qui fait
de la batterie c'est lui qui fait du
blocage style ouais c'est vachement dur
de marché bien jouer en fonction du
rythme il n'a aucune idée de mon
existence
triste fin gâteaux au cannabis tu aurais
dû lui dire allez coule pas vrai vous
vous sentez partir je crois que ma tête
est loin très loin de mes minuscule pied
salle hergé en tout cas s'est enroulé
ici chez ans et ma foi et rock
je vois bien que tu as mal
en fait rires non c'est important on me
demande le divorce
et moi aussi je souffre moi aussi j'ai
très mal c'est juste l'effet du gâteau
grenon c'est le mal le mal nous entoure
monfils a mal nous avons tous mal sauf
ma femme ce qui me fait mal parti site 1
- k en fait elle a mal mais cherche à le
cacher ouais je pense qu'elle doit avoir
mal non j'espère oui
ouais
[Musique]
redescendre
il va falloir que vous m'aidiez d'accord
le grenier peut être une salle de jeux
ou une chambre de plus je vous laisse
deux jours pour tout billet qui fait le
grand ménage
alors ça
[Musique]
cuche
à
qu'est ce que tu fais elle a gardé la
copie que j'avais pour le foot elle la
mettez sur la tête pour me faire rire
elle me connaissait tellement bien
[Musique]
elle fabriquait nos costumes pour chaque
halloween
une fois j'étais une chaussure droite
est elle la gauche j'ai aussi été un
jambon elle du fromage suisse et notre
voyage de noces dans les caïmans il y
avait un cyclone on n'est pas sortis on
enfilait tout notre équipement de
plongée et on a plongé dans notre
bonheur
[Musique]
et tous les jouets que tu as eue dans ta
vie les animaux avec des cornes se
faisait peur donc elle a acheté un serre
tête avec des oreilles de serre qu'elle
mettait et elle faisait le tour de la
maison
elle voulait que tu n'ai peur de rien
elle a gardé toutes les cartes
d'anniversaire et toutes les cartes
d'anniversaire de mariage
[Musique]
elle tout garder
elle a gardé toutes les petites choses
de nos vies elle a gardé tout ce qu'on a
vécu tous les trois
elle était toute ma vie
[Musique]
grandes marges de progrès fantastiques
votre endurance et au dessus de la
moyenne c'est extra
je suis désolé de vous interrompre chain
je suis venu vous annoncer que je
renonce à ma carte de membre à je
préfère m'entraîner en plein air
d'accord voici le docteur sayed rahman
c'est un des tout meilleurs
neurochirurgien du pays riches ont su
temps de grenaille l'a fait venir en
urgence pour remplacer un disque
lombaire aller à l'accueil rendre votre
carte sans rancune
au revoir je suis si fier de vous vous
savez désormais je suis confiant c'est
l'excitation
j'adore vous voir le faire un salut
quat'sous est en train de me faire un
faux kata qui juste pour nous
qu'est-ce que au revoir et bonne chance
mais c'est quoi ce délire du compte je
t'en prie
tâchons de rester courtois restons
courtois alors va te faire [ __ ]
j'en ai rien à cirer de ton petit cadeau
pitoyable pour sauver la face tu me
quittes pour qui et ne ment pas c'est
qu'il ma femme sait rien ta femme qui
n'est qu'un coup roulé je comprends que
tu sois énergie et merci pour le temps
qu'on a passé et désolé pour eux
sur ce jeu
sayonara alley cats ou fait on pas qu
attaquer
[Musique]
toulouse
oui mais
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nova
au revoir a dit khalid est ce que vous
avez viseur organise un barbecue comme
un art ya mieux à faire
attendez c'est pas le moment d'aller un
barbecue plus tard deux minutes tu
abandonnes ta danseuse je veux l'oublier
ok j'en ai marre de déprimer et depuis
que j'ai rencontré je fais que ça j'ai
pas envie de devenir hystérique que ça
en vaut pas la peine je t'assure que si
écoute moi devenir hystérique et le prix
à payer pour vivre une vie intense
tu apprécies à chaque petites choses de
la vie et à ne pas tout gâcher pour des
détails futiles qui en connaît un rayon
sur les pentes les doubles rancart et
moi mon rayon c'est l'amour je te
rappelle que tu divorces laisse moi
t'aimer et du cran laisse moi une chance
go dites lui de rester il y aura
d'autres barbecue meta danseuse étoile 1
leçon numéro un tu dois rentrer dans son
monde un grand ballet russe un grand
compositeur russe tchaïkovski le lac des
cygnes
pour faire simple c'est le prince
siegfried qui tombe amoureux d'une
princesse elle a été transformé en cygne
par un sorcier maléfique siegfried
rencontre un autre signe qu'il pense
être la princesse il décide de l'épouser
mais quand il réalise qu'il ya eu
méprise alors il retrouve la vraie et
tous les deux décident de se suicider en
se jetant dans le lac
j'allais sinon on dirait qu'elles n'ont
pas de sens alors allez on n'en déplaise
on l'a repris
on déplie l'autre jambe attention faites
le vite
ok on reste regardez c'est une question
d'équilibré ont détruit une jambe
ensuite la suivante et c'est alors qu'on
accélère et que c'est un facteur viii
quelque chose à craquer en dessous on y
voit de la glace
ça ne touche que tu sois là
peut-être que la glace n'était pas la
meilleure idée qui soit mes testicules
rapetisse je ne sens rien on devrait
peut-être changer de tactique dessine
suicidaire et des jeux de jambes je suis
sûr qu'elle appréciera t efforts au
moment fatidique
tu fais ceci
tu fais quoi là deux doigts sont
nécessaires et uqar et ça joue avec la
plus grande délicatesse et same nous
laisse moi faire avec une infinie
douceur laisse la glisse et dis toi que
c'est un pigeon la patte cassée
excellent et l'a tué sans le regard de
la mort
c'est quoi ce regard le regard un regard
qui veut dire tu es la solution à tous
les malheurs du monde à toutes les
questions qu'ils existent quelle
question ne pas laquelle
enfin il faut qu'elle soit vraiment
importante qu'elle soit même impossible
à formuler du genre et le regard
jamais une deuxième grue capable de
donner un tel regard à qui que ce soit
parce que tu n'avais jamais rencontré
que le cas quand même comme ça j'ai
l'impression que tu as perdu la tête pas
pour une femme regarde voilà ce que ça
donne quand on atteint la perfection
dans l'exécution
[Musique]
rires
m
[Musique]
je crois que t'as pas le truc moi aussi
mal trick bon merci je vais y aller
encore merci pour enfin que ces premiers
mois tu vas t'entraîner dans ma chambre
j'ai failli tout d'abord coque team ia
borussia c'est moi tu me reconnais et et
ensuite j'ai eu ton numéro par le
théâtre et si tu voulais je serais très
heureux 2 enfin ce serait génial que tu
veuilles eux me voir ce soir à l'asm
cactées l'un à l'assaut oui d'accord
appel à la présentation
ce serait génial donc on se voit tout à
l'heure enfin ce soir 12 belinga
daisy des nièces je vous en prie enlever
ça je voulais qu un mandat me voir et
elle elle vous prendra pour l'idiot du
village
que pensez-vous des chocolats pas
mauvais vous saviez qu'à une époque je
faisais 54 kg mon ex mari c'est à lui
que je dois à mon obésité
arrêtez vous êtes juste bien en chair
vous êtes à l'image de ces femmes du 17e
au avec leurs joues rosées déesse de la
fertilité oui c'est ça je vous vois
venir vous essayez de m'avoir au conflit
mme je vous jure
si vous décidez de m'aider vous serez
comme ce gouverneur qui appelle la
prison et qui proteste le laisser le
laissez le vivre c'est le nouvel an mais
d'accord revenez ce soir prendre
l'apéritif et est ramené du château
saint-jean qu'à berne et ses 90 dollars
la bouteille et ses délicieux acheté en
3 d'accord et du pâté en croûte et du
vacherin avec du jambon cru je m'en
occupe ou bien quand vous lui donnez
n'oubliez pas de lui dire oui qu'il y en
a beaucoup d'autres dans votre grenier
je m'en souviens au cas social et vous
en rêvez tu prenais du pain aux olives
tant que vous y êtes
ayad et fret avec un peu de crème
fraîche pour lutter d'accord vendus
à voir j'ai des projets pour ce soir
bochy tu vas aller à ton rencard avec 7
et ghana mais quoi il est où le problème
tu n'es pas sérieux de steve et comment
je dois m'habiller a l'air d'y toucher
c'est serré il faut que ce soit serré
tu portais vraiment ce genre de truc
quand elle était jeune elle trouvait que
je ressemblais au héros de son livre
fétiche et les grands romantiques suave
débonnaire l'impression d'être un garçon
d'honneur de cinq ans excellent humble
excellent tir allure
[Musique]
je crois qu'il vaut mieux que je parte
nom curtis excellente idée et curtis
c'est vous qui voyait un cracker oui
allez il faut manger
allez-y ben tu n'es pas obligé de vendre
la maison c'est là que justin a grandi
gars de là et peut-être qu'un jour tu
trouvera quelqu'un avec qui vivre tu
n'es pas sérieuse tu sais le temps qu'il
faut pour avoir un passé avec une
personne ça nécessite de recommencer
tout depuis le début
papa j'estime mon coeur j'arrive plus à
respirer calme-toi tiens qu'est ce qu'il
a non non ne te quitte pas une à rien il
croit qu'il ya une crise cardiaque
elle adore les fleurs et ma cravate mais
là on va dîner elle dit au revoir à ses
potes pour qu'on soit tous les deux
chaque pas respirer je suis sérieux
âgées plus de souffle je suis à deux
doigts de l'apoplexie écoute moi tout
ira bien
au début tu aura beaucoup de crises
cardiaques et même à la fin mai au
milieu quand tu commenceras la connaître
vraiment sa peur des écureuils sa haine
viscérale pour les défilés son amour
pour angel messia sa honte pour ses
doigts de pieds tordus et quand elle te
connaître à parker quand elle verra le
moment où tu regretteras de ne pas être
le médecin que tu voulais êtres et
keller a su être patiente
quand tu t'es fait happer par ta
carrière en espérant que tu finisses par
la réaliser mais ce n'est pas le cas et
qu'elle se sentait si seule qu'elle
n'avait d'autre choix que de te laisser
dans ton trou et faire quelque chose de
beau de sa vie et tu n'aura même pas la
dignité de l'accepter et quand après tu
t'es par pire en faire n'importe quoi de
ta vie elle allait chercher une personne
a aimé parler comme ça évidemment c'est
le mauvais cheval
et avec un peu de chance tu auras toute
la vie pour tenter de la reconquérir
elle finira par te donner une autre
chance parce que il fut un temps où elle
savait que du fond de son coeur qui en
valait la peine
j'ai absolument rien compris de ce que
tu as dit elle arrive et tu m'as pas été
[Musique]
bon je crois qu'il faut que je te laisse
tranquille ce soir je ne serai pas loin
et je t'en prie non tu peux rester car
tyre si c'est assez grand s'il veut
partir qu'il parte ben rentrer à la
maison tu ne le pense pas si j'ai une
haine comment placer
oui et ça m flea gare deux très grands
frères mais louis ii grand-mère excuse
pour toi alors comment ça se passe bien
il faut je raccroche à temps qu'est ce
qu'il ya je veux que tu essaie
d'imprimer cette soirée dans ta mémoire
de cette façon tu pourras t'en souvenir
un jour où tu auras le cafard j'y
penserai au revoir désolé mais qu'est ce
que vous faites vous êtes vraiment
quelqu'un de têtu
je n'ai aucun aspect pour fram je ne
vous aime pas je préfère me retirer
j'ai très bien compris que ce n'était
pas fini entre vous deux et pour être
honnête j'ai beaucoup mieux à faire que
ça félicitations vous êtes très noble et
je vous rassure je vous déteste aussi si
vous pensez que je vais oublier que vous
avez vu des magnifiques fesses de la
plus belle créature qui soit vous fait
une belle boulette
[Musique]
et je me disais que qu'il n'est pas si
tu as laissé à 30
très bien regagnez votre voiture
d'accord comment fait elle
au revoir ben
tu as faim et je pourrai manger
je n'arrivais même pas à mâcher de l'ol
on a souvent l'air bête en mangeant
quand on fait trop attention
elle a mangé une énorme salade du poulet
des haricots verts elle n'avait pas peur
de mâcher je crois surtout que rien ne
lui fait peur
moi j'ai pas pu manger une miette même
si je voulais des nausées a pas qu'un
peu moi aussi les maux de tête m'en
parle pas toi une douleur de ouf
c'est relaxant ne pas avoir à dire un
truc intelligent la minute
tu as déjà essayé de dire je suis
contente de voir en russe a appris à le
dire enfin je croyais apparemment j'ai
dit que j'étais content de la coudre cas
tu as eu de la chance il ya des verbes
plus dangereux le truc c'est que ça
valait la peine
tu me l'avais dit on croit qu'on va
crever et qu'on trouve la vie
insupportable way est aussi magnifique
alors en même temps l'amour
salt et d'amour
[Musique]
je suis très heureux que tu viennes
justin veut que je la vois danser
pourquoi est-ce que tu partes 1 ap ap
pourquoi vous êtes déguisé en pingouin
tous les deux c'est la dernière c'est
assez formel tu vois le genre il faut
que je repasse me changer on n'a pas le
temps je crois savoir ce que tu peux
porter une robe que tu portais il y à
quelques temps pendant que je fouillais
j'ai trouvé ceci est la porte et quand
on s'est enfui et qu'on sait marier en
cachette
tu crois vraiment que je vais rentrer
dans une robe que je portais ya 20 ans
[Musique]
on dirait que ça va
oh
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
papa
puis-je avoir cette danse
[Musique]
à croire que j'ai depuis gauche ça a
toujours été le cas
[Musique]
oh
je te chercher partout
qu'est-ce qui a signé plus gala s'il te
plaît essayez de le dire dans ma langue
fiodor il ne m'a pas vu danser mais
j'étais la voie juste vu ya ce maillot
mais tu n'es pas lui donc je suis quoi
décalé et je comprends pas ça veut dire
quoi
je suis rien je suis personne je suis un
looser t'es gentil
[Musique]
je vais te dire quelque chose
peut-être que ça te servira à jour
[Musique]
il n'ya pas pire mots que gentil dans
notre langue
[Musique]
on rentre et que fais tu vas rentrer à
viborg pour rejoindre son petit ami
fiodor qu'est ce qui m'a pris de croire
que je lui plaisais j'ai juste peut-être
pas l'habitude de ne pas plaire à une
fille je croyais quand même lui plaire
un peu diarra
[Musique]
allons-nous sort
non
venu j'arrive pas à croire que t'es
laissé mourir nos hortensias ces
criminels c'est que tu étais parti avec
l'arrosoir j'aurais dû lui donner mes
larmes
stop qu'est ce que tu lui as dit je lui
ai dit que de ne pas être aimé en retour
est toujours mieux que de ne pas avoir
aimé du tout et que contrairement à
d'autres personnes
son coeur cicatrisera en temps voulu
avec un peu de champ seulement d'être
sénile salut est ce que tu vas aller là
m'a appelé elle veut me voir
donc tu as déjà fait tentez pas vraiment
il faut juste un peu de temps je vous
adore
voyons pourquoi ne pas replanter les
hortensias voir le machu picchu dans un
premier temps faire du violoncelle et
revoir les nombres premiers
tu ne vas pas venir boire un café
je sais pas trop c'est qu'un café allez
viens arrête ne me regarde pas comme ça
mieux
[Musique]
il faut que j'aille me changer
qu'est-ce que tu regardes
[Musique]
non
amanda
[Musique]
tu te souviens de moi
s
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
guillaume
[Musique]
il connaît